[SIDE CONVERSATION]
MALE SPEAKER 1: All right,
again, thank you for coming.
We have a guest
speaker today, Victor,
to talk about going
screenless with YouTube.
I met Victor a few years ago.
We were co-workers, and
it was the first time
I had the opportunity
to learn how
to use the web through
screen readers.
Back then, I had no
idea that was possible,
and not only that, but I learned
from the engineering side
that you can do simple stuff
to make the whole web more
accessible to everyone.
Please help me welcome Victor
Tsaran from eBay, Paypal.
[APPLAUSE]
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
Hey, guys.
Can you hear me well?
Cool.
OK, start over.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, sorry.
OK, good.
I always need to hold
something in my hand
because otherwise-- It better
be hot and with caffeine.
Anyway, so thank you for coming.
This is great.
I hope we're going to learn
today something about YouTube
and a new user experience
probably for most of you,
and that is how you use
YouTube if you can't see.
So what I want to
start is by telling you
just a little bit about
myself because I'm
hoping that through
my personal story,
you will see why we really need
to worry about these things,
making things
accessible, and why
we need to worry, especially
about YouTube, making
available to everybody.
So I was born in Ukraine and
went through all the same stuff
like most of you, high
schools and things like that,
and then, when I entered
university, my real, sort of,
touch with the
world began, where
at the university,
as you know, you
need to deal with homeworks.
You need to deal with
a lot of teachers,
and you need to deal with
all kinds of situations
where you couldn't rely
anymore on your parents
to come and help you out
whenever you need it,
so the real life
challenges began.
How do you read something?
How do you take notes?
How do you take books
from the library?
How do you turn in your
homeworks and things like that?
And at that time, there
was really no technology
to speak of, at
least in Ukraine,
and so the only thing I could
do is rely on, so to speak,
human readers.
Right?
So every time you needed
some help you'd say,
can you help me out,
and of course, you
had to learn your
basics in diplomacy.
I call it Diplomacy
101 because you
got to be careful not to
step on people's toes,
and everybody's got
their own timeline.
And they have to
read their own books,
and they have to meet with their
dates and things like that.
And, you know, the girlfriend
is waiting and there's like,
hey, can you read for
me some philosophy book.
It's like, come on, get away.
So you do have to
learn how to really
be considerate of other people's
time, but at the same time,
while being able to achieve
your own goals, which
is for me, obviously, was
to complete my studies
and go in and get a job and be
as productive in life as I can.
So two years into my
studies, I got a scholarship
to come and study in
the United States.
It was a student
exchange program
for a year where one of
the things I had to learn
was computers.
It was like, wow,
this is so interesting
because up until that
time, I heard people
playing some games on Atari.
And my computer
science professor
told me, well, there's not
very much I can do for you.
You know, we could
probably learn
how to compose music
on the computer which
at that time as you
some of you may know,
you had to type in
the notes and it
was using the PCs
speaker buzzer.
So if you could call
it music, that's
what it was in those days.
And so at the end, we
just basically decided
there was really no sense for
me to attend in those computer
classes because
I couldn't really
benefit from them in any way.
So when I heard that I was
selected to go and study
in the United States, I was
like, wow, this is so cool.
Let's see what happens.
And the very first thing,
because I was a philosophy
major, of course, I was all
crazy about learning history,
and information was
the king for me.
Right?
It's like how much can
you remember, analytics,
and all that kind of critical
thinking that sort of stuff.
And so the very
first application
that I found when
using computers,
besides typing and doing
all the basic things,
is going to encyclopedia
and learning anything
I possibly could about
the world around me.
And it was just like,
wow, this is so cool,
not only that I could just
tap into this amazing wealth
of knowledge around me
just by using the keyboard,
but imagine, I didn't
have to ask anybody.
I just could log in into my
Unix box-- well, at that time,
it was DOS based,
but I was already
playing a little bit with Unix
and Pine and all the emails,
you know.
So I don't know how
many of you use Unix,
but I would imagine that many
of you, since you're engineers,
so we can speak common language.
You know, going in
terminal and using
IRC all this stuff
was exciting days.
But the most important thing
was this feel of independence.
You know, suddenly you could
just do things on your own,
and if things we're available
to you in the format, then
things just became so
much more pleasant to use.
And you could do it at
5 o'clock in the morning
if that's what you
wanted to do, and you
could do it totally
independent of everybody else.
And so that got me interested
in computer science.
So I went back to Ukraine, and
I established the first computer
center for the blind
where we taught students
how to use computers.
We created the first screen
reader program for blind users
in Ukraine.
And here you hear me mention
the word screen here,
so we're gonna hear and see
more of that as we move on.
And eventually-- so I
got back to the States.
I completed my computer
science degree.
After that, my wife and I--
actually, I met my wife there
at the exchange
program, so it there
was another big event for me.
And together, we traveled
in Southeast Asia teaching
computers to kids
in poor provinces,
so that was another
interesting experience,
not only because I could
actually apply my teaching
skills in computers,
but also, it
made me think about
things like jargon,
how much we take for granted
here when everybody speaks
English language, when
programmers understand
English language pretty
much since day one.
And now, you go
into another country
and you say something
like "sign in,"
and people like,
what do you mean?
What should I be doing?
So this made me think
about a lot of things
like, well, how do we use
language in computers.
What's understandable
for me may not
be understandable for
somebody whose English is not
at the same level or worse, for
whom computers is just a tool.
They're not programmers.
They're not even curious
by nature, for example.
They just need to be able
to type in their homework
and go get a job, perhaps,
even in the call center,
and computer for them
is just a tool just
like a hammer for a DIY person.
So it made me think
about that kind of stuff,
how do we go about translating.
There's also something
about cultural perception
of computers.
For Western cultures, where
technology is a bit more
of a normal thing,
many of us were
born with some kind of
technology, telephones,
television, computers, modems,
and all that kind of stuff.
So we're less scared
of that stuff,
but you go to countries where
people don't even have access
to white canes that blind
people use to walk around,
and suddenly, the
word "computers,"
not only that it's,
for many, unaffordable,
let's say it's-- We're in
a different time right now
because many more
things are affordable,
even in developing countries,
but just even getting used
to this idea of interacting with
a soulless piece of hardware,
for many cultures,
is a difficult thing.
So those are the things that
I learned, and with that, I
moved on and got a job in
DC doing some contracts
for the government, so that was
another interesting exercise
in learning how to
procrastinate and not do things.
You could get
really good at that,
especially seeing government
employees around you saying
like, well, you know,
I don't actually
have to do accessibility
because nobody's
going to fire me anyways,
so why would I bother?
So I had to practice my
Diplomacy 201, at that point,
on how to get people interested
in accessibility, which
actually worked out
really well because those
are the same skills-- when
I came to Silicon Valley
to work at Yahoo and
now, at Paypal, I'm
using those same skills
because guess what.
People here don't
really care about laws
or legal applications
or whatever it may be,
but people understand
human language and meaning.
When I talk to you guys or
to anybody else as humans
to humans, we can
understand that everybody
wants to make the
world a better place,
and oftentimes, all our
fighting and our battles
are about how we
go about doing it.
But as I mentioned before,
one of the big things I
did understand from my travel
and in teaching other people
is that in order to make people
feel a little closer to what
you're talking about, you
need to make them feel
the same feelings
you are feeling,
and especially when it
comes with the computers,
we're basically talking
about user experience.
Right?
User Experience 101.
And so what I
wanted to do today--
we will touch on the
engineering stuff
as much as you're
willing to go there,
and probably, this
is an inevitable.
We're gonna talk about
some technical applications
of accessibility, but
first and foremost, I
wanted you to go together
with me through the YouTube
interface and see,
or rather, hear,
what it feels like
to use YouTube
when you can't see the screen.
Now, before we even
go to YouTube--
I need to go in here--
I wanted to tell you
a little bit about the software
that actually makes it possible
because remember the
hammer for the DIY person.
Right?
You gotta know how to use
the hammer because otherwise,
you'll be left without fingers,
and so on and so forth.
Or worse yet, you might
be left without a house
if you don't know
what you are doing.
So same thing with
the computers-- right?
So I need to have
a tool that enables
me to be able to interact
with this piece of hardware,
and this tool is called a
screen reader, a little bit
an outdated term because
back in the dust days,
this is what this piece
of software used to do.
It literally would
read this screen,
try to interpret what
was going on the screen,
and then, speak it back to
you in a synthetic speech.
Synthetic speech,
back in those days,
was nothing close to
what you guys will
be hearing in a minute.
Back in those days
it was like aliens,
kind of like cyberspace, stuff
like, buh-buh-buh-buh-buh,
you know.
It was really, really hard.
I remember I had
such-- it took me just
two weeks to get used to
the toneless synthesizer,
and it not only was like
one dimensional stream,
but it also was
totally soulless.
I mean there was no intonation.
There was no articulation.
They've gotten better at that
because once they figured out,
you know, form an algorithm
and how you can raise speech
and so on and so
forth, they're like,
oh, you know, when there's
a question mark, even
that soulless voice,
we can actually
make it raise the
pitch a little bit.
But anyway, I digress.
So back in those
days, screen readers
used to read the screen.
Now, as we entered into the
world of Windows and Windows 95
and then, essentially, APIs,
screen readers no longer really
have to read the screen because
the way our screens look now,
people can't make sense of it.
You know?
Forget about computers
trying to make sense of it.
So really the most reliable way
to put screen readers right now
to interact with the
computer is through the API.
That starts from
the desktop APIs,
then goes into browser APIs, and
eventually, goes into-- well,
I wouldn't want to call DOM
API, but for the purpose
of this conversation,
we could call it an API
because it's an application
interface, as far as the web
page and the screen
reader is concerned.
Then, they go into the DOM.
So the reason I'm telling
you all of this is-- so now,
the screen reader, from being
this active tool that sort
of scans the screen and--
COMPUTER: Bye.
VICTOR TSARAN: --tries to
figure out what's on the screen,
it really becomes more of a
passive tool that sits there
and listens to what the
computer is telling it.
So for example, if I'm-- I
assume many of you here use
Macs right?
Anybody here use Windows?
Not a hand.
OK.
So I'll try to keep it
sort of cross platform.
I think a lot of the
concepts are similar,
but because I'm
using the Mac you're
gonna hear Mac pretty much
throughout this conversation.
So if I'm gonna go to the dock,
I'm gonna hit the shortcut key.
COMPUTER: Dock.
Google Chrome open, 22 of 28.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK,
let me slow it down.
COMPUTER: Default volume
one-- Default pitch, 51%.
Default intonation, 50%.
Default voice, Alex.
Default rate, 51-- 31-- 36%.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, I hope this
is a bit easier to understand.
COMPUTER: Google Chrome o--
VICTOR TSARAN: So what you
will notice here-- and in fact,
to give a little bit
better experience for you--
COMPUTER: Screen curtain on.
VICTOR TSARAN: So I'm
gonna turn off the screen.
I hope it did turn off.
What we're going to
do next is-- this
is a really important-- sorry.
I forget I need to be
close to the microphone.
--really important
piece of information
is that when you
use a screen reader,
it's like looking
through a straw.
When you get into the dark
room, and somebody told you,
at the end of the room, there
is something you need to find.
I'm talking the video
game kind of language.
What you're gonna
do is that you're
gonna start learning the
things about your room,
but you're gonna learn them one
by one because you can't see.
So you have no concept of
left corner, right corner,
and so this is how it feels
a little bit using the screen
reader.
So at this point, you
guys have seen the dock,
so it's a little unfair.
But if I ask you what's at
the end of the dock, what's
the last item on
the dock, I wonder
how many of you could say that.
And so when you use
the screen reader,
you have to explore
this one by one.
And the screen reader
will only speak the things
that are currently under
focus, a very important point
because I don't want the
screen reader to be jabbering
about anything and
everything on the screen.
I just want to be in control.
So let's explore this together.
So I'm gonna be using
left and right arrow
to go through the dock.
COMPUTER: Skype, 23 of 28.
Feedback assistant, 24 of 28.
Feedback assistant, 25 of 28.
Downloads folder, 27 of 28.
Trash, 28 of 28.
VICTOR TSARAN: Let's go--
COMPUTER: VMware
Fusion, 21 of 28.
Microsoft Lync, 20 of 20--
[INAUDIBLE], 19 of 20.
System preferences, 18
of-- App store, 17 of 28.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK,
so you got the idea.
Right?
A couple of things that happened
there is that the API started
giving the screen reader
a couple of pieces
of information.
Number one, they give it a
name-- right? --of what exactly
you're pointing at, obviously
very important-- right?
--because you need to
know what application.
They tell you something
about, probably
you noticed, 23 of 28,
and so on and so forth.
Right?
So it's giving you the size
of this particular element
in this particular widget
that's going to be dock.
So I kind of know how big-- Am I
supposed to go through 55 icons
or is it going to be just 28.
Right?
Little bit of information,
but quite important.
How many of you
were able to hear
if there were any folders there,
and if yes, then how many?
Cool.
Yeah, you got it.
So there was a downloads
folder, quite important.
Right?
There's a downloads
folder so the user knows,
I know, in this
instance, that there
is a folder as opposed to--
COMPUTER: iBooks, 16 of 28.
VICTOR TSARAN: All right?
As opposed to just
an icon because I'm
going to behave differently
based on that information
that I just received.
And most of you know,
of course, folder
means that it's
not an app, so I'm
gonna be probably looking for
it to have some files in there
or whatever it is.
OK.
Before I'm going to
turn on this screen,
let's do one more
little exercise.
The next one I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna open the menu bar--
and one thing you will
already notice right here,
which I'm sure is obvious,
but I want to point it out.
I'm not using mouse here
at all, so everything I do
is through keyboard exclusively.
So that means if there's any
piece of this interface that
does not have a shortcut key
or I cannot tap to, it means
it's inaccessible
to me completely.
Well, not exactly, but for the
purpose of this conversation,
it's inaccessible to me.
So what I'm gonna to do is
I'm gonna go to the menu bar.
So I'm gonna hit the
shortcut key which
is provided by my screen reader.
COMPUTER: Menu bar, Apple.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, so I
heard the word "menu bar."
Again, I know which context I am
currently in, super important.
And anything else
you guys heard there?
Right.
So what is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah, you got it.
So it's basically the title
of the particular menu.
Let's see if I can ask my screen
reader how to navigate that.
COMPUTER: This item
has no help tag.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK,
that's not good.
So I ask it can you
tell me how to navigate.
I guess they assume
that everybody
knows how to navigate
the menu bar.
Well, I'll be using the left
and right arrow keys, and so--
COMPUTER: Chrome.
VICTOR TSARAN: This
is not the menu.
COMPUTER: File.
Edit.
View.
History.
Bookmarks.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
So let me go down in
one of these menus,
so I'm going to go to,
let's say, Chrome menu.
COMPUTER: Hit Edit.
Fi-- Chrome.
Chrome menu, 12 items.
VICTOR TSARAN: All right.
So there's 12 items in the menu.
And then, I can
just go down arrow.
COMPUTER: About Google Chrome.
Preferences, Ellipsis,
Command, Comma.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
How much did we
learn from this one?
Anybody?
You?
Yeah, there's a shortcut.
You are right.
Anything else?
Let me play to you this again.
OK?
COMPUTER: Preferences,
Ellipsis, Command, Comma.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Yeah, this is cool.
So what do you see
visually normally?
I think normally you see--
I think it is ellipses.
Right?
What does it mean
to you, visually?
AUDIENCE: There's a dialogue.
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah,
there's a dialogue.
Actually, some screen readers
go as far as they will actually,
instead of ellipsis, they
just simply say, dialogue.
So they would say--
COMPUTER: Preferences,
Ellipsis, Command, Comma.
VICTOR TSARAN: So they would
say, preference, a dialogue.
A very important context,
again, right here, you see.
So now that I know
that it's ellipsis,
then I know this is gonna
be a dialogue if I open
this particular
menu, and there's
a shortcut cue, which you
correctly pointed out.
COMPUTER: Signed in as
vtsaran@gmail.com, Ellipsis.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
COMPUTER: Clear Browsing Data,
Ellipsis, Command, Shift,
Delete.
Import Bookmarks and
Settings, Ellipsis.
Services, Submenu.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK,
what about this one?
You know it.
Go ahead.
COMPUTER: Hide Google Chrome,
Command, H. Services, Submenu.
VICTOR TSARAN: Yes, correct.
So it says that
there is a submenu.
Right?
Obviously, there is a difference
between Ellipsis and Submenu.
Ellipsis means that the
dialogue is gonna open,
and Submenu is gonna mean
that there is just menu items.
COMPUTER: This item--
Services, Subme--
VICTOR TSARAN: Cool.
And then, I just use right
arrow keys, and I open the menu.
COMPUTER: Screen curtain off.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
I'm gonna put the
screen back on.
COMPUTER: Closing menu.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, cool.
So this is basically
how the navigation
happens on a desktop.
So I'm not using any slides
today, so if you warn me,
I can take notes, but I'm
sure you guys can take notes.
There are a couple
of things here
I just want to
summarize for you.
What the screen
reader needs to be
successful in letting
the user navigate,
well, number one, the user needs
to be able to get to the item.
Right?
So there's some kind of keyboard
access involved, whether it's
tab, whether it's arrow keys,
depending on the context.
Number two, we need a
title, so everything-- well,
let me actually say,
name, not the title,
because that's gonna be
a little misleading when
we talk about the web.
So everything needs
a name of sorts,
we call it accessible name,
but that's more of an API talk.
Then, we need to
know the context.
Right?
We need to know a--
yeah, I guess, a context.
Menu bar.
Is this a menu?
It would also mean, for
example, are we in a check box?
Is this a button?
And so on and so forth.
Because knowing that,
the screen reader usually
will be able to figure out or
know, at least, what they're
supposed to do with this
piece of information.
And then, we need
some kind of state.
Right?
So in the case of list, it
may be size of the list.
In the case of
check box, it may be
whether the item is
checked or unchecked,
and in the case of menu, it's
whether the menu contains
a submenu, whatever it may be.
And so with these three
pieces of information,
the user, for the
most part, should
be able to figure out
the basic interface.
So--
COMPUTER: Safari.
VICTOR TSARAN: So let
me go now to the browser
because I think that's
what we want to look at.
COMPUTER: Safari.
VICTOR TSARAN: So one of the
things we find on the web
is that it's a bit
less predictable.
When you work with desktop
APIs, they're pretty good.
And also, tomorrow
or after tomorrow,
if you come up to a computer,
you power it up, most likely,
your desktop is gonna look
the way you left it yesterday.
Right?
Unless you let your kids
or partners or whoever mess
around while you sleep.
But for the most part, if you're
in control of your machine,
you know that you're
gonna turn it on.
Icons are gonna be
in the same places.
The dock is going to
be in the same place.
Well, it's not the
same case with the web.
Right?
Web is far less predictable as
far as this stuff is concerned,
so when we talk about the web,
the principals I just described
a couple minutes ago
are, I would say,
they're so much more applicable.
You have to be like super
disciplined to make sure
that all of your stuff has
items, has names, and has
states and all that
[INAUDIBLE] stuff.
Because on the
desktop, let's say,
once I know my desktop--
maybe, let's say,
if certain buttons
don't have names,
I mean, you know, life
sucks, but maybe I
could remember them.
It's number five, so I just
like arrow key five times,
and I get there.
On the web, I can't even predict
that I'm gonna go to YouTube
and it's gonna look the same
tomorrow because you guys just
pushed an new update
or is it the beta
or maybe I got into
one of the buckets.
Who knows?
Right?
And so this stuff comes
so super important
that you can't let it slip.
There's almost no excuse because
you can totally lose the user,
and the experience
could be disastrous.
So why don't we have a quick
look at the YouTube page.
And by the way, if you
guys have any questions,
feel free to interrupt me
because if you don't interrupt
me, I may be talking here
for another three hours.
And I don't know.
How much time do
we actually have?
Is it an hour?
MALE SPEAKER 2:
We've got an hour--
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, cool.
OK, so I'll try to stay
close to the clock as I can.
OK, so here's the
very first thing
I'm gonna let you know is
that the-- well, you may have
guessed-- the screen
reader is a pretty
configurable piece of software.
All right?
It's not one size fits
for all because just
like there are many
preferences people have,
starting from clothes
to colors, going
to browsers and
toolbars and whatnot.
The screen reader
obviously isn't
going to be the
same for everybody.
Some users may want
to speed it up.
Others may want to slow it down.
Some users--
COMPUTER: Default pitch--
Default rate, 36%.
Default voice, Alex.
VICTOR TSARAN: Some users--
COMPUTER: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Some users may
want to use different voice.
COMPUTER: Def-- Alex.
VICTOR TSARAN: Some users
use different languages.
I speak several languages,
so I have several speech
synthesizers that I-- even
on YouTube, when I go in,
if I want to read
descriptions in that language,
I'll just switch to a
different synthesizer.
Some platforms have
gotten so smart
like iPhone, for example, that
if it detects a link attribute,
it's gonna switch the speech
synthesizer on the fly.
So on the iPhone, because it has
25 built-in speech synthesizers
for different languages,
if I go to a page that
contains multiple
languages, it's
gonna automatically switch
between the languages.
A good example would
be wikipedia.org.
When you go and there are
links in multiple languages,
they use their language
attribute really well,
and so when I go
through Wikipedia
and it says which language is
the Wikipedia is available in,
VoiceOver, the screen
reader on the iPhone,
is pretty smart to
switch those languages
on the fly, which is
really, really cool.
We don't have that,
unfortunately, on VoiceOver
on the desktop.
Although, the feature has
been discussed many times,
and hopefully, we'll
make it, one day, there.
OK.
The other thing that
screen readers do really
well is that they know
that one of the reasons
we're using the
computers-- we, I
mean blind people--
is that we want
to be as efficient as you guys.
I don't want to be
going to the website
and-- while you can
scroll over the mouse
and click, click, click,
click, in three seconds,
you're doing your things.
Right?
I don't want to be tabbing
through the whole website
every time I go to YouTube
or any other website.
Although, I could.
It's certainly not the
most efficient way.
Right?
If I looked at this page--
let's just have a look here.
COMPUTER: Form controls.
Two-- Headings.
Links, 571 items.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK?
So this thing has 571 links.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: My sub--
VICTOR TSARAN: And
that's only provided you
guys have done your job right
and you have all your hrefs
and you don't do onclick
stuff and things like that.
Even with that, there's
still 571 tab stops.
That's not something
I want to do.
I don't think you
want to do that.
Often times, though,
to be honest with you,
especially beginner
users, that's
what they do because sometimes,
they don't know what to expect,
and also, there is a
population of users who
lost their sight
late in life, which
means they're not as adaptable.
I lost my sight when I was five,
so I'm pretty adapted by now,
but there are a lot of people
who lose their sight at 40, 45,
and in addition to
psychological barrier, I mean,
they've got technical
barriers to deal with.
Now, suddenly, they don't
have that "look at the screen
and get going" kind of attitude.
Now, they have to look
through this straw
the way everybody else does.
And so they do start
tabbing, and it
gets really, really frustrating.
But once you get more
proficient with screen readers,
you start looking for other ways
to improve the way to navigate,
and one of those things is,
you probably heard about,
is called HTML headings.
And they're there for a reason
because with HTML headings,
if they're present on the
page, the screen reader
can take advantage of them.
Because remember, it's
looking through the DOM,
and it says, how many h1's,
h2's, h3's can I find there.
And if it finds them,
here's how it looks.
COMPUTER: Links.
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm
gonna pull this up
with a screen reader and--
COMPUTER: Headings, 199 items.
VICTOR TSARAN: Still a lot, but
five times fewer than links.
Right?
And more importantly,
not only are there
fewer headings
than links, there's
also something I can
learn about the page,
and there, I must say, you guys
are doing a pretty good job
because your page is
pretty well-structured,
at least the home page.
Once you get off the
home page, things
get a little less predictable,
but we're looking at home page
right now.
Do you see there's a
number right next to each
heading, to the left of it?
And that's telling
you what level,
whether it's two or three.
So we can see here--
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Two-- What to Watch.
Three-- Playlists.
Three-- Subscription.
Two-- Recommended.
Three-- three-- three-- three--
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm
just gonna go through
that because
otherwise, you know--
COMPUTER: Three-- 20.
VICTOR TSARAN: So
you've got the idea.
But you already see
some of the things
that I would be
talking about, just
by looking at the heading list.
Right?
Even though they're headings--
COMPUTER: Three-- 18,
2,000, 14-- Three-- 20.
VICTOR TSARAN: Uh, what?
Oh, that's in Ukraine.
That's right.
OK, sorry, sorry,
sorry. [INAUDIBLE]
COMPUTER: Three--
VICTOR TSARAN: Anyway,
so you can see now
how I can take advantage
of that information.
Well--
COMPUTER: My subscript--
VICTOR TSARAN: Once I
learn my screen reader,
I can actually tell
the screen reader
to go just between
headings, too.
So this way, since you
guys done pretty good job,
and I just want to look
at what major sections are
available in this page, there
are several ways I can do that.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Vis--
VICTOR TSARAN: So I can
find the heading level two.
COMPUTER: Heading level two--
What to Watch, clickable.
VICTOR TSARAN: And then I
can tell my screen reader,
OK, go to the next
heading level two.
COMPUTER: Heading level
two-- Recommended.
Heading level two-- two items.
[CLICK]
24, recommended channel
for you, clickable.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Yeah, this is where
it should be switching to
a different language, but--
COMPUTER: Heading level two--
[CLICK]
Associated Press.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, you also
hear something interesting.
Did any of you notice
little click there?
Like makes this click?
COMPUTER: Heading level
two-- 2-- Heading level two--
[CLICK]
Associated Press.
VICTOR TSARAN: Now, why this?
You hear the click.
Normally, you'll
hear the word "link,"
but because I'm a
bit more proficient
and I don't want to hear
link, link, link, link, link,
link, I told my screen
reader just to play a sound.
So whenever there's a
link, it'll play a sound,
and it'll play different sounds
for drop down, check boxes,
and things like that.
It depends on the screen,
but some of them go crazy.
Chromebox, which is the
Google's own speech solution,
does a really good job with
what they call earcons,
and they really do
a pretty good-- I
like the way Google Chromebox
actually uses sounds.
Sometimes, it's a bit too
much, but for the most part,
it's pretty good.
And so most screen readers will
have some kind of functionality
to substitute controls
by sound, but remember,
they need that semantic
piece of information
to be able to know what sound
to play because if the screen
reader doesn't know
that it's a link,
guess what, it's not
going to play the sound.
OK, so we got through headings.
This is pretty good, and you
can see I can go back and forth.
I also have an
ability to-- so let's
say if I go to heading three.
COMPUTER: Heading level three--
[CLICK]
Raw, colon.
Big rig stuck in Illinois swamp.
VICTOR TSARAN: All right.
So then, I can move
my screen reader
to next level heading three.
COMPUTER: Heading level three--
[CLICK]
Obama advisor skips
House hearing.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, and
so on and so forth.
Now, when I hear a link, I
obviously can activate it.
In this case, since
I know it's a link--
COMPUTER: Heading level three--
VICTOR TSARAN: I
can open the video.
COMPUTER: Obama advisor
skips House hearing, press.
[CLICK]
Obama advisor skips
house hearing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --to gather facts about the
White House Office of Political
and Strategic Outreach.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
So I want to have
a look at this page
because this is where many
users spend their time.
So the very first thing
I hear from users--
and I wanted to let you know.
I know there's obviously
business decisions behind this.
I wanted to let you know
because I hear this from users
all the time,
especially blind users
are not big fans when the video
starts playing automatically.
Why?
Oftentimes, you just want
to read the description.
You may not even want
to watch the video.
And so let's see how fast we can
find the play controls in here.
So I'm right here on the page.
I open the page, so at
this point, remember, guys,
the straw.
Right?
Can you imagine the straw?
Straw, straw, straw, straw.
Right?
I don't know what's
on this page.
I'm just gonna start
tapping, see what I can find.
COMPUTER: Try something new.
Search, search text field.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, so you placed
me into the search by default.
COMPUTER: Search button.
Play button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, cool.
So at least of
the play controls,
and I think you've
been using the tab
index to do some
of these things.
So this is probably
for the right reason.
I could understand why this is
done, and this is probably--
COMPUTER: Caps lock.
Caps lock off--
VICTOR TSARAN: Sorry.
Well, the users can quickly
jump to the play, play button.
Let's tab through this thing.
COMPUTER: New toggle button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, new toggle.
Button.
COMPUTER: 100% volume slider.
VICTOR TSARAN: This is good.
Let's see here.
COMPUTER: This item
has no help t--
VICTOR TSARAN: [INAUDIBLE]
COMPUTER: Watch later button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, watch later.
COMPUTER: Settings button.
Theater mode button.
Full screen button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
COMPUTER: Visited image.
YouTube home.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK--
COMPUTER: YouTube home.
VICTOR TSARAN: We're back
into the navigation bar.
OK.
Here's a question for you.
What's missing here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: It's OK.
We didn't get there.
Remember, I always
have my headings.
I didn't even start
looking at that,
but what would you be doing
with a video like that.
I mean, come on.
It's a government video.
Would you want to
skip around and--
OK.
So what's missing here?
Yeah, and-- How many of
you guys use shortcut keys?
Do you know what
the shortcut keys
are for skipping
around the video?
Somebody said no.
OK, cool.
Well, guess what.
I would know either if I
didn't read it somewhere
or I didn't go,
you know-- So, OK,
without being too mysterious,
there are two problems.
One you have already
identified which is the seat
control itself.
I don't actually even know
where it is on the screen.
I think it's somewhere
because I believe
if you start using
shortcut keys,
it eventually gains the focus,
but the bigger problem here
is that you guys have this
fabulous facility for shortcut
keys.
If use j and l, it lets you
actually rewind and forward
the video, and if you use k,
it lets you play and pause.
Pretty cool, but how
would you know about it.
All right?
So discoverability
of these features
is something I would like to
encourage you to think about,
and you have a good
examples around Google.
So for example, if you press
question mark on many Google
websites, it's gonna pull up
the lists of shortcut keys.
So you can rely on some
of those known techniques
to let users know, hey,
we've got these really
amazing shortcut
keys to think about.
Twitter has done something
even more interesting.
When you load this
Twitter page, twitter.com,
for the first time, they
play this hidden message
for screen reader
users, and it says,
did you know that Twitter
has shortcut keys.
Press question mark to read all
of the available shortcut keys.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Guide.
VICTOR TSARAN: Actually,
do you have question mark?
Let's try.
No, I don't think so.
OK.
So for those of you
who didn't know,
there are shortcut keys,
j and l, to move forward
and backward and k's pausing.
This is really cool.
Honestly speaking though,
to be honest with you,
I'd love to see though j and
k to move between videos.
That would be really
cool, but anyway, that's
not for me to decide.
So remember about these things.
Right?
Discoverability is a big
thing, and the easier
you can make it for screen
reader users to discover stuff,
the happier they
will be overall.
OK.
So--
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Vi-- Theater mode.
Set-- Watch later.
100-- Mute to-- Play button.
Mute toggle button.
VICTOR TSARAN: So
let's mute this.
COMPUTER: 1-- Unmute
toggle button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Good.
So that works really well.
COMPUTER: Press
unmute toggle button.
1-- Mute toggle--
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, so let's
have a look at the settings
for-- I understand this is
the settings for the video.
COMPUTER: 100% volume slider.
Watch later button.
Settings button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
This is settings for the video.
Is that correct?
My assumption's correct?
Or this is for the player.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: See you guys
are, yourself, you're not sure.
OK.
Just kidding.
So maybe a better
label would be,
potentially, but
that's only level two.
So anyway, let's go
to the Settings panel.
So I'm gonna hit enter on this.
COMPUTER: Annotations-- on, off.
Speed-- normal.
Quality-- auto, paren left,
360p, right paren, group.
VICTOR TSARAN: Great.
So probably a div
came up on the screen
and it's reading the
contents of the whole div.
OK.
I mean, you know, whatever.
I will not worry about
that particular part,
but what I'm worried about
is the actual controls.
So let's have a quick look.
I'm gonna tab
through this thing.
COMPUTER: On button.
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm just pausing
so you guys have a chance
to process it.
OK, let's go next.
COMPUTER: Off button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Hm, OK.
Are these two separate things
or part of the same thing?
Oh, it's even worse.
Yeah, thanks.
COMPUTER: Normal button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Who are
we talking about here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Right.
This is a speed, so
it's really a combo box.
Yeah, thanks for letting
me know, by the way.
That's good.
OK, cool.
Let's go next.
COMPUTER: Auto, left paren,
360p, right paren, button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Let's see.
This is DPI?
No, [INAUDIBLE].
Quality.
Right, right.
Sorry.
Yeah.
OK.
So but this says-- it's not
clear because it says auto
and then, it says 300--
COMPUTER: Auto, left
paren, 360p, right--
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh, OK.
This is the auto, which
is 360-- OK, cool.
So but I assume this is
also drop down, then.
So let's press Enter on
this and see what happens.
COMPUTER: 360p,
240p, auto, group.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
So the new div came up.
Let me see if I
can use arrow keys.
Nope.
OK.
Let's see tab.
COMPUTER: 360p button.
240p button.
Auto button.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Well, you see here--
so even though, technically,
it's accessible,
from the user
point of view, it's
confusing because now,
you don't actually
know this is drop down.
Right?
It looks like separate controls,
and because they don't really
have labels, you could easily
get confused by thinking,
oh, these are totally
three different things
I'm looking at.
So you can see the
drop down's different,
and I see this all
over YouTube, so
I'm just showing
you some examples.
I assume you guys are gonna
be doing your homework.
But the drop down is
definitely something
I would like you
guys to see, looking
at because you
have a lot of them,
and they're super important.
Right?
Because a lot of
that stuff allows
you to configure your
YouTube experience,
so I think this is definitely
something worth looking at.
OK, so I press Escape.
I don't exactly
know-- I presume.
I don't know if it
collapsed anything.
COMPUTER: Play button.
Search bu--
VICTOR TSARAN: I think it
collapsed the Settings panel.
Now, notice one thing.
What happened here is--
and I see this quite a lot.
I keep fighting
about this at Paypal
as well-- is that what we need
in terms of keyboard focus
is every time you collapse
an expandable region
or div or panels.
I'm even afraid to say the
right term because there's so
many terms, sight
panel, over panel,
under panel, floating panel,
fly out, fly under, fly over,
and so on and so forth.
You hear designers
using that term.
Then you're like, OK, whatever.
Just call it panel.
Anytime there's a panel
that comes up on the screen
and the user
collapses it, you want
to make sure the focus comes
back to the place we started.
Why?
In your instance, maybe
it's less of an issue
because you placed me back
somewhere around the Play
button, but this is
not always the case.
So the user may end up,
and they're not sure
if they're supposed
to tab forward
or backward because they want
to be where they were before.
So remember, this
rule, very important.
Whenever you collapse something,
your focus should go back to
where?
You guys tell me.
Where were before?
Settings.
Right?
COMPUTER: 65-- Play button.
Mute to-- Settings button.
VICTOR TSARAN: So
I want to be here.
There's something else about
these so these buttons,
in particular, this
panel Settings.
How would you know actually
that this is a drop down?
You wouldn't know that.
Right?
Because it actually says button.
Moreover, this Settings
actually isn't even a drop down.
It's actually an
expandable region.
So here I want to
mention something.
How many of you guys
are familiar with ARIA?
Anybody here knows about ARIA?
OK.
So wherever we
can, obviously, we
encourage people to
use native controls.
I know that browsers are pretty
unforgiving as far as letting
us to style native controls,
and especially drop downs
are really a pain in
the dot, dot, dot.
So we need to rely on
ARIA in many instances
to make these things accessible.
But before we even get to
ARIA which is even the sugar,
really, because it provides
important semantic information,
or I like to call
it super semantics,
provides this information, but
really, first and foremost, we
really need to start with
the keyboard interaction.
Right?
Once you get that
worked out, then we
can start working on ARIA.
COMPUTER: Spotlight
search text field.
Safari-- TextMate--
VICTOR TSARAN: So one of the
things you could be doing here
is-- for those of you-- I heard
only people on the left side
said they know
about ARIA, so I'll
not to go too deep into
it, but essentially,
think of ARIA as
auxiliary markup
that you can pepper
your HTML code with,
and it'll sort of provide
additional information
for the stuff that's not
natively available in HTML.
Some good examples
would be tab panels.
COMPUTER: Tab panels.
VICTOR TSARAN: And
we got sliders.
There's nothing in
HTML like a slider.
Well, we have some
stuff in HTML5
like type in close
range and stuff,
but it's not even supported
well by old browsers
and assistive technology so
we're in a bit of a problem
there.
Yeah, so we got tab panels.
We've got sliders.
What else do we got?
I mean, even pop-ups.
Right?
COMPUTER: Pop-ups.
New lot.
VICTOR TSARAN: So ARIA, it
stands for Advanced Rich
Internet Applications into
W3 spec at this point,
and what it is, as I mentioned,
it's an additional markup
that you can specify
inside your HTML
to give additional
meaning to your controls.
So let's say we're
talking about settings.
What could we do
with the settings
to improve the
functionality there?
Well we could do
something like--
COMPUTER: Less div.
VICTOR TSARAN: Let's just say--
COMPUTER: Id equals quote.
VICTOR TSARAN: --ID settings--
Less, button, greater, settings,
less, Settings, less, less,
less, slash, div, greater.
VICTOR TSARAN: Well, you know,
this is a button, that's OK,
but it's not really a button.
So what can we do to make this
work better for screen reader
users?
Well, one way we could
do this, you could say--
COMPUTER: O, n,
greater, less, button.
VICTOR TSARAN: You
could say, ARIA--
COMPUTER: ARIA, dash.
VICTOR TSARAN: Pop-up--
COMPUTER: ARIA,
dash, has greater.
VICTOR TSARAN: And when you
do that, the screen reader is
going to announce,
settings button has pop-up.
And then, of course, you still
have to do all your JavaScript
things with keyboard controls,
keyboard focus, and stuff
like that, but this is
how simple this stuff is.
Right?
Now, there's more
about ARIA than this.
I was just doing
one little example,
but this could be one way you
could replicate this problem.
And unfortunately for
expendable, collapsible
regions, we don't really have
a native solution in HTML,
so we have to rely
on ARIA to provider
that auxiliary information.
COMPUTER: Safar--
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, so we
looked at those panels.
Now, let's go to the video.
Let me just check,
quickly, the time.
COMPUTER: July 25, 11:53 AM.
VICTOR TSARAN: Wow, I
knew that I would talk--
COMPUTER: Heading level one--
Obama advisor skips House--
VICTOR TSARAN: So
again, you guys
are doing good job here
because your heading level
one is actually the
title of the video.
I really, really like that
because if I pulled up
the list of headings--
COMPUTER: Headings, 12 item--
two-- one-- Obama advi--
VICTOR TSARAN: This is
my heading level one.
All right?
And what I want to see
because this is the reason
I came to this page.
COMPUTER: Heading level--
VICTOR TSARAN: There's one.
[ALERT]
COMPUTER: Image--
Associated Press.
VICTOR TSARAN: All right.
Cool.
So the next thing we're
going to look at-- so
we're looking at the
video which is great.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Associated Press.
Headings-- Form-- Landmarks--
Images-- five items.
YouTube home image.
[KNOCK]
Featured under--
Associated-- Featured
underscore channel
dot jpeg image.
Associated Press image.
Photo dot jpeg image.
Default dot jpeg image.
Default.
VICTOR TSARAN: So I'm sure all
of you know about alt text.
Right?
So I do want to mention a
couple of things about alt text
because Marcel told
me there are always
lot of questions about this.
It's one of those
interesting topics
that while so
seemingly tiny compared
to other interesting
and complex things
we have to deal with
today in Web 2.0,
but it is yet the
one that's often
overlooked because
it so much has
to do with the way we
perceive information that it's
oftentimes not easy to
analyze it by a computer.
So a couple of things I
want to point out here.
I'm looking at a couple
of images on this page.
There is one you wouldn't
notice doesn't have an alt text.
Right?
This guy.
COMPUTER: Associated--
Featured underscore
channel dot jpeg image.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK?
And then, there are
a couple of others
I wanted to let you know about.
This guy.
COMPUTER: Photo dot jpeg image.
VICTOR TSARAN: And this guy.
COMPUTER: Default
dot jpeg image.
VICTOR TSARAN: So what I
would suggest because you
guys are using the little
thumbnails on YouTube,
and your images are an important
part of sort of experience
to enhance how people
look at YouTube.
Think carefully.
Not every image needs to
have an alt attribute.
Right?
Some images,
perhaps, it's better
if they don't even
have any alt attribute,
or I should say differently,
but like these two images, photo
and default, honestly speaking,
it's a waste of my time
because I have to go
through this stuff
and I was like, I hear photo.
I don't know what
photo it is, so if you
want to really provide
a good experience,
you either put in
enough metadata
to say what kind of photo it is
or just maybe even completely
silence it.
Or things like default.
I don't even know what
exactly this is referring to.
COMPUTER: Default dot jpeg.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Let's have a look.
[KNOCK]
COMPUTER: Upload.
Guide.
Collapsed--
VICTOR TSARAN: I don't
even know where it was.
Anyway, so--
COMPUTER: TextMate.
Left-- New-- [KNOCKING]
VICTOR TSARAN: It's
very simple, again,
if you want to have your images
and have no alt text, you just
put empty--
COMPUTER: Alt equal.
VICTOR TSARAN:
--around this stuff,
and basically, you're telling
the screen reader, shut up.
There's no image.
Forget about it.
All right?
If you do have alt text,
you just do alt equals
COMPUTER: Alt--
VICTOR TSARAN:
--obviously, and then, just
put whatever text maybe.
Let's just say if
it's Obama's picture--
I don't know what
happened, like Obama--
COMPUTER: Alt, at
the White House.
VICTOR TSARAN: Maybe you
can put the word "photo."
COMPUTER: Left paren, quote,
new lo-- alt equals, quote,
Obama at the White House, left
paren, photo, right paren,
quote.
VICTOR TSARAN: So
I always prefer
if you do want to say that
it's a photo or a thumbnail,
put it at the very end
because ultimately, user
is going to know that it's
an image because the screen
reader is already
going to tell them,
image, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So really, they just need
to know that it's an image,
and if you don't have
enough information just
get rid of that stuff.
It's really probably
wasting your bytes as well.
OK.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Upload.
Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah,
those are the things
you guys have a lot of.
COMPUTER: Button.
Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Do you know
what those things are actually?
I don't even know.
COMPUTER: Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh,
let me move the focus.
COMPUTER: Button.
Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Can you see now?
Oh, Google+.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh.
COMPUTER: Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: So this is like
to sign on to-- no, what is it?
COMPUTER: Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, so
then we need to talk.
So this is a widget that you
probably inject from Google+.
Right?
COMPUTER: Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, cool.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Image.
Associated Press.
[CLICK]
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
This is another very
interesting pattern
that occurs quite a lot
on using content websites.
When you have a thumbnail
or a logo of a company,
and you wanted to
make it clickable.
Right?
So you can't really
wrap it up with an href,
so what we end up doing is
that we have two tab stops.
Right?
We end up with two tab stop.
I don't think
that's intentional.
One tab stop is a
clickable image.
In this case, it's a
log of Associated Press,
if I understand this
correctly, and the other one
is the actual-- I would
imagine it's a website.
Right?
Let's just check this.
COMPUTER:
https://www.youtube.com/channel/uc52--
VICTOR TSARAN: This is gonna
take me to their channel.
Let's look at the
URL on their image.
COMPUTER: Image.
Asso--
https://www.youtube.com/channel/--
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
So you see we have the same
target, but two tap stops.
So if I'm looking at the channel
that has a bunch of videos,
it basically means that I
have to tab twice per video.
Right?
So there's a bunch of
solutions people thought about.
One idea would be to use
tab index equals minus 1.
So you can take the
stuff out of tab order.
Another thing maybe
to think about,
maybe this is where you
don't want to make into href.
Make it a clickable element, but
at least a screen reader user
isn't going to be
able to tap to that.
So I leave it up to you how
you guys solve this problem,
but I just wanted to show it
to you that this is actually
occurring quite a lot.
[CLICK]
COMPUTER: Button.
I like this.
Like button.
Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
I see this quite a lot.
Obviously, I want to like
or dislike the videos, and--
COMPUTER: Unsubscribe button.
[CLICK]
Associated-- Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
What's this one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh, OK.
OK, cool.
So that's quite important.
Right?
So you see you guys,
already labels.
Even if all of you did just
go through all of these things
and make sure you
have accessible names,
you'd be like 70% good.
Anyway, let's go tab again.
COMPUTER: I like this--
VICTOR TSARAN: Yes, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: If you use a
disable attribute, it will.
Yeah.
So use either
disable attribute--
we can also use an ARIA element.
ARIA, there's
disabled equals true.
But if you can, I
would use disable
because it's probably gonna
also expose it to the browser.
So you do you have that.
Yeah.
And it'll definitely--
it's gonna
tell me dimmed or
something like that.
It depends on the screen reader.
VoiceOver on the Mac is
gonna tell you dimmed,
and VoiceOver on Windows
is gonna say grayed out.
They have different terminology,
but it will say something.
COMPUTER: Button.
I like this.
Like button.
VICTOR TSARAN: I like
this like like what?
It's like an oxymoron.
Right?
COMPUTER: Button.
I like this.
Like button.
VICTOR TSARAN: So what should I
do now if I-- Like do I like it
or dislike it?
Anyway, you get the idea.
Right?
COMPUTER: I dislike this button.
VICTOR TSARAN: It actually
sounds kind of cool.
I dislike this button.
See?
It's like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: No,
the reader just
did [INAUDIBLE] I dislike this.
It's of course for fun.
It's not your fault.
But anyway, I think you
have the same problem
with-- I've seen it.
I can't remember
right now, but there's
a button when they ask
you to unsubscribe--
Let me see if it's here.
COMPUTER: About button.
Share button.
Add to button.
Report button.
http://smarturl.it/associatedpress.
http:/-- It's a smart URL?
Something, I don't know.
Whatever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: No, I will.
Yeah, OK.
COMPUTER: Unsubscribe button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah, it
seems like it's been fixed.
It used to be the
same problem, but it
would say subscribed,
unsubscribed, subscribed,
like three times or
something, similar to what
we see with "I like
this like," but I think
maybe somebody already
figured that out.
COMPUTER: I like--
I dislike-- About.
Share.
VICTOR TSARAN: Let's look at the
sharing one because that's-- I
think we're gonna--
COMPUTER:
Http://youtu.be/lhvlumlig3g
content selected edit text.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
So even though this is super
obvious that this is a URL,
some kind of label would be
really nice that says something
like URL to share
or address to share.
Right?
So for me this is obvious.
I read [INAUDIBLE] HTTP.
I mean, maybe other
users don't know.
Is it a Tweet widget?
Is it a share?
So keeping the labels in
mine, and let's actually
see if there's a
label on the screen.
[ALERT]
COMPUTER: http:--
Button.
http-- Start at, colon-- http:--
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
I don't think there's a label.
So you rely on the fact that the
visual users know what it is.
Right?
So do you do in this situation?
So I'm gonna give you
a couple of things.
COMPUTER: TextMate-- Text--
VICTOR TSARAN: Let's say your
designers are like, no, we're
not gonna put tape.
It's gonna steal our pixels.
Nah, no way.
COMPUTER: All-- New line.
VICTOR TSARAN: Welcome to
ARIA, so we have, again,
a possibility here.
If I have--
COMPUTER: Less input.
Type equal--
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm
not gonna use quotes.
I'll save myself a bit of time.
Type equals text, and
blah, blah, blah--
COMPUTER: Period.
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm gonna say--
COMPUTER: Greater.
VICTOR TSARAN: --there's
some kind of URL.
COMPUTER: Left bracket.
Greater.
Left bracket.
URL.
Address.
Slash Less.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, cool.
COMPUTER: New line.
VICTOR TSARAN: Let it be.
COMPUTER: Less-- y-- t--
VICTOR TSARAN: So
what you can do is--
COMPUTER: Tango.
VICTOR TSARAN: ARIA provides
you with a really cool attribute
called ARIA Label.
COMPUTER: ARIA, dash.
ARIA, dash, lab--
VICTOR TSARAN: Here I can say
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VICTOR TSARAN: So when the
screen reader notices this,
it's gonna read it as
if it was a valid label.
So this is perfect
in situations where
you know visually it's
so apparent that you're
sharing the URL.
It's like why do we even bother.
Right?
But again, remember, you
can not always rely on that,
so you have ARIA Label
attribute that you
can use in this instance.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah,
this is a great question.
Dragon, naturally
speaking, isn't
known to support
ARIA unfortunately,
and we've been fighting
with them-- well,
we, I can't say
that I have been,
but the community
has been fighting
with them because
unfortunately, they
think of themselves--
well, unfortunately--
they think of themselves
as a mainstream tool
and as a result, yes, they are
an accessibility tool, assisted
technological tool, but
they don't go as far
as supporting some of the
accessibility standards.
So you wouldn't be able
to say click on URL
to share or something like that.
It wouldn't understand it.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Sorry?
VICTOR TSARAN: Well,
not me, personally,
but there are people who
are hammering [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: No, it
has the same effect
as the Label for tag.
And by the way, the
problem with placeholders
that there can be-- well, if
you use a placeholder the way
it's supposed to be which
is use an HTML placeholder.
Right?
Then, it's OK.
But if you use placeholder
as some people do,
which will place a
text in the field
and we think it's a
label, it's not advisory
because the problem
is that when you
move your focus into the field,
the label disappears usually.
Right?
Well, then that means
the screen reader
isn't gonna know what's
the label of this field.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, cool.
So let me just
finish this widget,
and then, we can
get to questions.
OK?
Cool.
COMPUTER: Space.
Space.
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm just
tabbing, by the way.
Oh, wait.
COMPUTER: Space.
Space.
VICTOR TSARAN: Apologies.
COMPUTER: Safari.
Safari.
VICTOR TSARAN: My mistake.
COMPUTER: Button.
http:-- 0:07 Content selected.
Edit text.
VICTOR TSARAN:
See, this is where
it would get really
super confusing.
So now, somebody's
going what is this.
It's probably
something about time.
You guys know what
it is visually.
You know it's to start.
This is, by the way, a really
cool feature, the coolest ever.
I love this, and the fact you
can even look at it through API
is even super cool.
Anyway--
COMPUTER: Share
your thoughts group.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Share your thoughts,
I guess it's like a div.
Let's look at this.
COMPUTER: Top comments
text, one of one.
VICTOR TSARAN: Ooh.
COMPUTER: Leaving list box.
Share your thoughts
gr-- New line.
Insertion on word
[BEEP]
Edit text.
VICTOR TSARAN: Same thing.
Right?
So I just hit Enter in
"share your thoughts."
COMPUTER: New line.
VICTOR TSARAN: And I'm
in some kind of rich text
which I assume I can
probably type in.
COMPUTER: New line.
Leaving frame.
0:-- ht-- Share-- Button.
Button.
http-- button.
Share to LiveJournal button.
Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Who's
using LiveJournal still?
Wow.
COMPUTER: Ht-- Share to
Digg button list, 13 items.
Share to button.
VICTOR TSARAN: And this guy?
Yeah, I guess--
COMPUTER: Button.
Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: Anyway,
you get the idea.
So those are some of the
things, just to quickly
summarize for you guys again.
So the heading structure
you're doing really
well from what I've seen so far.
Remember about the
labels on form fields,
on buttons, and
things like that.
We don't want to hear button,
button, button, button.
Alt text-- if you don't
have enough information
for the images, just use
alt equals empty quotes.
Otherwise, provide
something meaningful.
Drop downs and
expandable panels.
Use ARIA.
We have ARIA pop-up
and so on and so forth.
This is probably a
separate conversation,
but ARIA is very
powerful that way.
And yeah, I think, then, we
can just get to questions.
I did want to mention something
that I talked to Marcel about.
I noticed that you
guys are refreshing
the content on some pages.
The middle of the
page gets refreshed.
That's causing some
really weird things
because the keyboard focus
gets totally screwed up.
Especially in Chrome,
for some reason,
I see this more
than in Safari, is
that I will be looking
at the list of videos,
and then, suddenly, my
focus jumps somewhere else
completely.
So that's something maybe we
can talk after if you guys can
get together for
lunch or whatever.
We can chat about this.
I see this is as one
of the big problems.
Should we go to
questions quickly?
MALE SPEAKER 3: Yeah,
have some questions here.
One is regarding the
[INAUDIBLE] and also
[INAUDIBLE] mobile [INAUDIBLE]
information [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah.
OK.
Those are great questions.
So the skip ad I
didn't get to, but it's
one of things that actually
has [INAUDIBLE] annoying.
So I tried to reproduce
it because-- yeah.
But it was hard because every
time we'd go to a video,
it's either different ad
or-- so if you guys have
any reproducible
scenarios, I'd love
to be able to show this to you.
So there are two issues
we have with skip ad.
Number one, when
the ad is playing,
there's actually
no keyboard control
that I was able to ever find
that lets me to actually skip
the advertising.
That's number one.
So even if I knew that there's
actually a skip function
item-- Number two,
I don't even know
that functionality is available.
Remember we talked
about discoverability,
about keyboard shortcuts
and stuff like that?
COMPUTER: TextMa--
VICTOR TSARAN:
One little trick I
want to show, but be
careful when using this.
COMPUTER: New-- Less-- New--
VICTOR TSARAN: So
what we have with ARIA
is something called
Live Regions.
So you can have a hidden
region on your page
that when it gets updated,
could be automatically spoken
to a screen reader.
Sometimes, it can be used
on the live data which
means the information that's
already on the screen.
Sometimes, you can
use it as a way
to feed some information
to screen reader users.
I prefer the former because
the few hidden things
we have on the page, the
better for everybody.
It's probably less work
for your QA people,
less work for translators
to figure out stuff.
But here we go.
So we have Live
ARIA Regions, so--
COMPUTER: Less div.
VICTOR TSARAN: --let's say
we have something like--
COMPUTER: Id equals quote.
Id equals quote.
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm just
sort of speculating here,
and let's say--
COMPUTER: Less-- Less
slash-- Less-- Id equ--
VICTOR TSARAN: We're gonna
to have here, when it's
30 seconds into the ad, I'm
gonna pop in this screen
it says--
VICTOR TSARAN AND COMPUTER:
You can now skip this ad.
VICTOR TSARAN: So the
problem, this is a div.
Right?
It's not focused.
A screen reader doesn't
know of its existence.
How did you tell the user
that this text has actually
been just shown on the screen?
One way we can do this is by--
COMPUTER: Spa--
VICTOR TSARAN: --using something
called ARIA Live Region.
COMPUTER: ARIA-- ARIA dash.
ARIA dash live equals space.
VICTOR TSARAN: So there are
two types of Live Regions,
polite and assertive.
Polite will politely
wait until the user is
done tabbing or
typing or whatever,
and then, it's gonna speak.
Assertive is totally rude.
It's like I don't care.
I have to tell this
to you right now.
So perhaps, let's say,
if you were in a chat,
you may not want to be
interrupting the user because,
let's say, they are
typing the message,
and they're listening to a
screen reader as they type.
Right?
You don't want to be intruding.
Right.
So that could be one
of the best examples.
So in this instance,
because the user probably
is mostly listening, I think
it's OK to be assertive.
And so one way to do this, you
could be injecting a stream
here, and every
time you inject it,
the screen reader
is gonna react.
COMPUTER: Less input.
VICTOR TSARAN: Now,
Live Regions are
a little bit interesting
beasts in that,
depending on what screen
reader you're using,
you may need to do a little
bit of hacking around.
COMPUTER: Addr-- Right bracket.
Less-- New-- Less div ARIA--
Greater, quote, great-- Space.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Here's a good one.
COMPUTER: Dash.
Dash.
Greater.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Oops, I misspelled.
[SPEAKING WHAT IS BEING TYPED]
VICTOR TSARAN: ARIA
atomic is attribute
that says no matter what,
update the Live Region.
I don't want to lose
you at this point.
All I wanted to show you
guys is that Live Regions can
be used to communicate some
changes on the screen that
happen, but for example,
the keyboard focus
is not currently pointing at.
You can also use,
instead of using--
COMPUTER: Less input.
VICTOR TSARAN: For example,
if you have model--
COMPUTER: New li--
VICTOR TSARAN: --model alert.
You could also be
using something
called ARIA role equals alert.
COMPUTER: Role equ--
VICTOR TSARAN: So you
basically place it on the div,
and whenever there is alert
on the page, it'll say alert.
It's time you go
get some coffee.
You've been spending too much
time on YouTube or whatever.
So ARIA provides you with all
these interesting attributes,
and you can look at this spec.
I'm sure Marcel would be
a good person to talk to.
You've spent some
time with ARIA before.
There's a great spec.
There's a lot of
stuff on the websites
that shows you good
examples, but I
think because YouTube
is so dynamic,
you may find some
good applications.
Be careful though.
I do want to warn you.
You can overdo
stuff, and that can
have totally adverse results.
So as every tool, make sure
you know exactly what you're
doing so that you
don't confuse the user.
Any other questions?
MALE SPEAKER 3: Yeah,
we have a question
regarding auto-play [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: No,
no, so they-- yeah.
It was actually
easier than that.
Because they did it off
screen, so the message
they put up-- let me
just show you actually.
COMPUTER: Safari.
Safari.
VICTOR TSARAN: I
don't know actually--
COMPUTER: New tab.
Search Google.
M-- Twitter page has
20 links, two headings.
VICTOR TSARAN: Let's see.
If I go to the
top of this page--
[ALERT]
COMPUTER: Visited.
[KNOCK]
[CLICK]
Language.
Vis--
VICTOR TSARAN: No,
it didn't work.
I think it remembers me.
What they do, they put a tax,
but they make it invisible.
So they use a negative
pixel positioning,
or they use a clip property.
You put a text on the
page, and then, you just
do clip rectangle one
pixel in all four corners.
And so if you're not
using a screen reader,
you're not gonna
even know it's there.
So if you use Flash-- which I
hope you don't-- unfortunately,
we don't have an easy way
to detect screen readers
in the browser at this point.
There was a way of
doing it through Flash,
but as Flash is going away,
we don't have that feature
anymore.
So I don't exactly know.
One way that somebody suggested
to me on Twitter today
in the morning is that
if there was a setting
that the user could go to
and just check a check box,
play video automatically,
that would be kind of cool.
So this way, you don't
get your business folks
upset, but at the same
time, the users who
know that there
is a setting, they
could just go in and
check the check box.
And from then on,
they're not gonna
have their video
playing automatically.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: What?
VICTOR TSARAN: Right.
No, I totally
understand, but what if--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: It could be.
Then, you have to
make sure you're
write it for all browsers.
Right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: So I was
thinking the setting could be--
but they don't even
want people to be
able to turn off the feature.
Right?
But what if it could
be another analytics?
How many people actually
turn on the video?
Right?
So you could think
of it that way, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: No, those are
great discussions to have.
I'm not trying to-- Look, I
work for business-- I totally
understand the priorities
and things like that,
but I just bring it
to your attention
that this is a
concern among users.
Well, the way
VoiceOver on Mac OS
solved this problem was
actually pretty smart.
They have this feature
called Audio Docking, and--
COMPUTER: Language--
VICTOR TSARAN:
--what it does if--
COMPUTER: Reload.
User name or email.
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh, wait.
Sorry.
COMPUTER: Obama adv--
Button list 13--
VICTOR TSARAN: So notice
what's gonna happen here.
COMPUTER: Right pointing--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So if you need a vehicle
for your small business--
COMPUTER: Guide button.
Button.
- --or even if you
think you don't.
I invite you to join me.
The right--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VICTOR TSARAN: So you
notice what happens.
Right?
When the video is
playing, the voice
over ducks down the video,
so that the user can still
hear the screen reader.
I think it's a pretty
clever solution, personally.
I don't actually know
why others-- and they
do the same on the iPhone.
If you're using a Mac,
it's really not that bad,
but if you're using
Windows, then I
could see why people
could be upset.
I'll leave it up you to
decide what to do with it.
I just thought I'd
communicate the problem.
Anyway, anything else?
We're done.
Right?
So I guess if I
have to leave you
with one thing it's that I
know it's a little scary.
Every time you ask
developers to go and try
with a screen reader,
people go, oh, what can
I do so I don't have to do it.
Right?
But honestly, it will open
your eyes to many things
that you thought you developed
really well, and so just
going through the
experience, it's
gonna help you just to
discover a lot of things,
not just about accessibility,
but just overall.
Imagine yourself
using the keyboard.
So I would suggest, if you can,
spend 10 minutes, 15 minutes,
just going through
the interface.
And just make it into a
habit, and that's just
gonna make you a
better programmer
and bring you a little closer
to how users who are blind,
specifically, use your
particular product.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Oh, yeah.
So-- Yeah, OK.
So this is the one
I'm using here.
It's called VoiceOver.
It's built into every Mac.
If you press Command-5--
COMPUTER: VoiceOver off.
VoiceOver on.
Safari.
VICTOR TSARAN: It's built
in, so that's really--
you get it for free.
If you're testing on Windows,
there's a project called NVDA ,
NVDA, which is an open
source screen readers,
so that's gonna take
care of Windows.
And of course, you
do have Chromebox
in Chrome, which
is also a solution.
I know Marcel told
me that there is
a little bit of a
concern among developers
that you have to learn
how screen readers work.
There is a bit of truth in that
which is you do kind of need
to know how it operates.
For example, remember I
mentioned at the beginning
that tabbing is not
the only thing you
need to do with a screen reader.
But honestly speaking, there
are only a few shortcut keys
you need to know to be
able to be effective.
So remember I showed
you this feature?
COMPUTER: Images.
VICTOR TSARAN: It's
called web rotor.
I can never pronounce
this properly.
Bleh.
This word, R-O-T-O-R.
And basically,
when a screen reader is running,
if I press Command-Option-u,
this opens up, and look.
This is a quick-- right
there you can already
see what's going on here.
Right?
And then use left
and right arrow keys
to switch between
different categories.
COMPUTER: Buttons, 57 items.
Guide button.
Button.
Search-- Play-- Mute-- Full--
Theater-- Setting-- Cap--
Watch later--
VICTOR TSARAN: You don't
even have to use any tool.
Then, you go right arrow again.
COMPUTER: Links, 90 items.
110892817022189601849 1.
VICTOR TSARAN:
That's a good link.
I like that.
COMPUTER: Https:/--
Loyal to liberty.
Three hours ago.
112493291332271681279 1.
VICTOR TSARAN: Do you
guys start realizing
why you have 500 links?
It's because actually
I think there's
some things on the
page that really don't
have to be links like this guy.
COMPUTER: Three hours ago.
VICTOR TSARAN: I'm not sure.
Maybe my thinking is screwed
up, but I don't quite
see why this should be a link.
I mean, I know you want to
make everything clickable.
That's probably the idea.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: Right, yeah, but
that's not what the links says.
Right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR TSARAN: I know.
Got it.
So that's what the link is.
OK.
So anyways, so then,
you know go right again.
COMPUTER: Headings.
VICTOR TSARAN: Headings.
COMPUTER: Form controls.
VICTOR TSARAN: You've got form
controls, and so you can use--
COMPUTER: Button.
Button.
Search button.
VICTOR TSARAN: So just using
even this particular feature,
you can quickly see
how well your page is
doing with the voice over.
And so this is just one
shortcut, Control-option-u.
COMPUTER: Button.
VICTOR TSARAN: But I'd
be happy to follow up
with a couple of links.
I'll make sure
Marcel to send you
a couple of links, some
quick guides on how
to use a screen reader.
I would encourage you,
don't stress too much.
Learn one or two
things about the screen
reader, and rely on those.
The point is not to make
you into experienced users.
The point is for you
to be able to feel
comfortable with the tool enough
so you can test for yourself.
OK?
Thanks so much, and I
hope I'll get a change
to talk to some
of you afterwards.
[APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
VICTOR TSARAN: Yeah.
In the Google
accessibility, there's
a lot of really cool guys, so
you're gonna have lots of fun.
Thanks a lot.